there was this one from a couple days
ago obviously we had hurricane Ian here
in Florida and the devastation is still
being cleaned up all over Southwest
Florida right now Kamala Harris went for
an interview on C-Span and she came out
in essence I mean she already was but
she went full racist and full communist
can you talk just a little bit about the
relief efforts obviously of a hurricane
in and what the administration has been
doing to address the climate crisis in
the States but I'm just a little
follow-up because this is important to
me
we consider the global implications of
emissions right the poorest countries
are affected the most they contribute to
the least and are affected the most so
how should voters in the U.S feel about
the administration's long-term goals
when it comes to being an international
influencer on this topic
it is a crisis as it ever as evidenced
as you've mentioned by Ian by the
wildfires happening in California the
floods the Hurricanes but also because
of America's
leadership and what it should be
globally on this issue
and so that has happened and it will
Propel a lot of good work
um the the crisis is real and the clock
is ticking and the urgency with which we
must act is without any question and the
way that we think of it in the way I
think of it is both in terms of the
human toll and I know we are all
thinking about the families in Florida
in Puerto Rico with Fiona
um in in and what we need to do to help
them in terms of an immediate response
and aid but also what we need to do to
help restore communities and build
communities back up in a way that they
can be resilient not to mention adapt to
these extreme weather conditions which
are part of the future on the point that
you made about disparities you know when
I was back when I was district attorney
of San Francisco I was elected in 2003.
I started one of the first environmental
justice units of nad's office in the
country focused on this issue and in
particular particularly on the
disparities as you have described
rightly which is that it is our lowest
income communities and our communities
of color
that are most impacted by these extreme
conditions and and impacted by by issues
that are not of their own making and so
I mean
absolutely and so we have to address
this in a way that is about giving
resources based on Equity understanding
that we we fight for equality but we
also need to fight for Equity
understanding not everyone starts out at
the same place
and if we want people to be in an equal
Place sometimes we have to take into
account those disparities what she said
there at the end let's let's do the
Communist part first she wants everyone
to end up in the same place that is not
congruent with the American dream what
the American dream says is hey we've got
equality
and some people start with more some
people start with less less some people
have great gifts some people don't some
people come from great families some
people come from broken families there's
the Gestalt of life that is uh just out
there and if we have equal laws for
everyone it might be harder for some
people and easier for some but plenty of
people are born rich and end up poor and
plenty of people are born poor and end
up rich it's the chance you got a chance
man in the United States that's what
it's all about the idea that you'd want
all people to end up in the same place
uh no you wouldn't want all people to
end up in the same place that is what
communism is if you want to see how the
media and the political Elite lie about
everything and how they launder their
lies through the system this is
absolutely perfect so here's a tweet by
Andrew Bates now Andrew Bates is the
Deputy press secretary to the White
House I think he works right under
Corrine John Pierre she's the press
secretary he's the deputy press
secretary so he quotes PolitiFact and
the New York Times and Reuters all
claiming that she did not say what we
just heard her say that it had something
to do with race uh PolitiFact no Kamala
Harris didn't say Hurricane Relief would
be based on skin color actually she did
we just played you guys the video so
there's he quotes politifacts So
PolitiFact Is a website that lies they
claim to be a fact checking site but
they lie because she did say it would be
based on skin color she said communities
of color then he quotes the New York
Times conservatives distort Harris's
remarks about Hurricane Relief so it's
ah you see those conservatives they
pounced those mean conservatives nobody
distorted it she's the one that said
Equity should be built in and she's the
one who brought up skin color go back to
it one more time then Reuters
deliberately distorted we played it for
you straight up